[Musique]
sur la riviera varoise jean paul
belmondo
ce n'est évidemment pas un effet du
hasard il est tourner un film pierrot le
fou sous la direction de jean luc godard
qui impose parfois certains risques à
son interprète
[Musique]
l'impression se fait jean paul ii banque
est passée sous un train grâce à la
pression que moi je rêve je vais me
suicider en se jetant sous un train
j'ai apprécié que vous êtes partis au
tout dernier moment oui en chopent un on
va peut-être aller encore plus preuve on
se prend à peine de se faire accrocher
plus passer par itunes u 10 u oui
fenêtres les aucune appréhension avant
ce genre de scène ça paraît simple mais
c'est même dangereux pour la prévention
non parce que quand même j'ai de bonnes
jambes je sais que je peux courir et me
lever à temps avant que le travail
[Musique]
jean-paul une longue patience le cinéma
est ce que vous faites entre les prises
rien j'admire la merde
est-ce que c'est air détendu signifie
chez vous une différence des
contractions par rapport ce qui se fait
alors des contractions pointu ferme même
ça va être assez difficile alors comme
ça de but en blanc de rentrer dans le
rôle dans la peau du personnage et puis
d'en ressortir pour regarder le paysage
ou lire les journaux sportifs
non pas du tout c'est comme ça c'est
plus reposant à ce que si j'étais toute
la journée dans le rôle et même entre
les prises à tête entre les mains de ce
marcheur a fatigués mais je prends le
css courtes un peu comme les au théâtre
les acteurs sont à cette heure dans
l'horloge qui pensent leur rôle car ado
qui peuvent arriver à 20h55 et puis dans
le dans le trou tout de suite
inutile de vous demander à quelle
catégorie vous appartenez au hasard du
tournage cette découverte macabre et les
complications qui vont en découler
et je vous fais de la moto j'ai entendu
du bruit
j'habite en dessous
le budget
[Musique]
au stade de la réalisation il est très
difficile de bien comprendre un film à
plus forte raison lorsqu'il s'agit d'un
film de godard ce pierrot le fou aux
prises avec des tueurs par est inspiré
directement de l'actualité il ya
quelques années mais est ce bien du même
qu'il s'agit de carry trade
ça n'a rien à voir le côté non
conformiste du personnage de vous plaire
parce que vous êtes un peu comme cela
sans être pour autant un gangster n'irai
pas jusque là
pourtant lorsque l'on interprétait un
rôle on prétend qu'il y à une nécessité
d'identification au moins partielle de
l'individu au personnage qu'il
interprète avant mais ça je crois pas là
c'est ce que ce procédé les jambes ça
parce que par moi j'ai joué léon morin
prêtre a très bien joué et gangsters qui
devance 6 juin drogué ou un fait dire à
ce propos que j'irai jusqu'à ce point là
pour faire pour être bien drôle faut de
l'imagination c'est mieux que vous ne
verriez l'ecclésiastique sur moi qu'on
puisse vivre non se portait pas
spécialement la soute à mais faut les
observer crois que c'est un peu ça le
métier d'acteur c'est d'observer les
gens et après l'arrivée à faire ce
qu'ils font mais je crois que justement
il ya un bail à certains accords qu'ils
font mais toute une légende où il faut
vivre ce rôle jusqu'à devenir sa et les
fronts liger joue un fou et j'ai fait
difficile j'étais jeune mince affaire
pour moi c'est pas du tout mon style je
crois que le cinéma il faut beaucoup de
spontanéité souris et avec godard c'est
facile de pouvoir faire saint jean luc
godard vous savez que belmondo de
travailler avec vous dans des conditions
qui sont parce que celle du reportage
parce que c'est vous jean luc godard il
accepterait pas cela d'un autre volet
prônant travaillent dans des conditions
de simplicité mais je parlais au point
de vue scénario vous travaillez votre
scénario votre texte jour le jour par la
veille souffel lendemain la pression
dans un bain lui il avait ça comme il
est aussi paresseux
- faire mon travail de son tempérament
très élevé qui vous rapproche
qu'est ce que j'apprécie le plus chez
lui en dehors de lecteurs bien sûr je
connais pas très bien
enfin comme
c'est la disponibilité en a certaines
formes de gentillesse qui fait que l'eau
disponible et prêt
à partir affronter à faire quelque chose
enfin joué à exister une grande qualité
trouver un acteur c'est quand un art
bien le signaler aux côtés de jean paul
belmondo anna karin ces quelques bouts
de seins glanées ça et là ne s'engage
révélateur tout au plus permettent ils
de situer les personnages et encore vous
entendez bien avec jean paul belmondo
très bien surtout que je suis ravi de
travailler avec jean paul parce que j'ai
l'impression que moi j'ai toujours le
trac de toute façon alors mais avec jean
paul jean paul il a une manière d'être
qui tellement naturel qui tellement
c'est vraiment le grand acteur et avec
lui on ne sait pas ça se passe comme ça
se passe très bien je crois
comment se fait-il votre avis qu'ils
plaisent tellement aux femmes moi je
pense parce que jean-paul il a du charme
et je crois que c'est ce qu'il ya de
plus important c'est quand on a du
charme il ya du talent il est
parent est pas bobo me lis pas mal pour
jean-paul vous tournez film sur film mr
d'or du cinéma comment organisez-vous
votre vue harbart nord du film j'ai ma
famille j'ai mes enfants
et puis j'ai tous les copains et
heureusement je n'ai entre chaque film
j'ai quand même des vacances la presse
celui là là j'ai pas de trois mois
d'aller passer dans le midi avec toute
la petite famille votre femme comment
prend tel ce long déplacement et que
vous effectuez rythmant jr extrême
orient notamment valu à l'aller venu à
hong kong est venu passer un mois à hong
kong à quoi sert elle partage un peu
entre eux entre les enfants et moi elle
veut penser que vous êtes soumis à de
nombreuses tentations puisque vous
tourner avec les plus belles filles du
monde a rêvé assez belle elle est très
belle aussi redire pour moi c'était la
plus belle alors à la base 100 fans
loupé le médeçin à ces messieurs ne
faisait pas de scène deux s'inquiétant
qu'elle présenterait pas jalouse c'est
qu'elle n'aimerait pas alors je dire
quoi si si elle était actrice et qu'elle
tourne dans les boîtes centre aniston
maroc bande aux fins d'être elle aussi
est ce que ça vous ennuie
ah oui savoir dire est mort fin j'ai
fait confiance
vous pouvez comprendre alors que de
temps en temps ce buste ennuyeuse
fabrice je comprends très bien
elle a bon caractère un très bon
caractère rue si je vous comprends bien
pour vous donne l'impression que ça peut
durer longtemps comme son existence le
cinéma d'un côté la famille de l'autre
mais j'aimerais que ça dure le plus
longtemps possible pas agréable
on peut jamais savoir ce qui se passe
pas dans la vie mais je souhaite que ça
dure
vous êtes jamais dit tout de même qui a
eu beaucoup de choses ah si je crois que
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance puisque tu as
réussi j'ai joué pendant longtemps au
théâtre et ce n'était pas la fin je
m'attendais pas devenir tron appelle une
vedette et j'ai eu beaucoup de chance
avant de rencontrer chabrol en retrait
godard qui m'ont fait faire du cinéma et
des premiers rôles et qui m'ont placé